alors oui vous non vous peut-être oui
vous ne pense pas
d'après une étude récente une personne
sur deux estime passé à côté de sa vie
j'en faisais partie à 6 ans quand je
suis arrivé en école de commerce je me
suis pris une claque on nous faisait
rêver de carrière dans le marketing ou
la finance
pour ma part j'avais plutôt l'impression
d'être sur des rails et de filer tout
droit vers la crise de la quarantaine
j'aime beaucoup écrire et j'ai retrouvé
les feuilles de cette époque où
j'écrivais alors c'est ça grandir
renoncé à trouver un job qui nous fait
vivre et je me sens tellement
spectateurs de ma vie j'en étais là avec
mes désillusions de jeunes adultes à me
dire bon clairement n'est pas heureux
alors on fait quoi c'est quoi le plan b
j'étais en quête de sens j'avais envie
d'autre chose mais je ne savais pas quoi
alors j'ai cherché
ça a duré trois ans jusqu'à découvrir
l'entrepreneuriat social
un entrepreneur social c'est comme un
entrepreneur classique business mais
avec un projet d'intérêt général
avec son équipe ils essaient de résoudre
un problème de société le chômage le
cancer l'accès à l'eau le sexisme la
pollution le plus connu c'est le
professeur yunus prix nobel de la paix
il est à l'origine du concept de micro
crédit qui consiste à prêter de l'argent
aux personnes les plus pauvres pour les
aider à monter leur commerce et ça a
permis à des millions de personnes de
sortir de l'extrême pauvreté
à ce moment là c'était comme si je
découvrais un monde parallèle dont on ne
soupçonnait pas du tout l'existence et
où des gens se bouger tous les jours
pour construire un monde un peu meilleur
par exemple voici microdon une start up
qui vous propose de faire la ronde il
encaisse dans de nombreux magasins ça
consiste à agrandir votre facture à
l'euro supérieur faire passer votre
course de 8 euros 50 à 9 euros et de
reverser l'écart de 50 centimes par
exemple à la croix rouge qui avec 3
euros c'est à dire l'équivalent de cinq
six personnes qui font un arrondi en
caisse va pouvoir aider une personne
sans abri à se tenir propre en lui
offrant un kit d'hygiène avec une brosse
à dents un peigne et c'est un autre
projet j'aime beaucoup s'appelle let's
do it s'attaque à un problème de société
complètement différent partout dans le
monde des entreprises et les
particuliers jettent leurs ordures un
peu n'importe où dans la nature sacrée
des décharges sauvages qui défigurent
les paysages un bord d'autoroute une
plage une forêt on se retrouve à manger
des poissons qui ont mangé nos propres
et emballages plastiques
ça devient un problème de santé publique
let's do it
c'est une association qui organise des
rassemblements massifs pour nettoyer les
zones les plus sales d'un pays en une
journée
la première édition a eu lieu en estonie
et armés de gants et de sacs poubelles
4% de la population s'est mobilisée en
cinq heures ils ont nettoyé leur pays
de fil en aiguille je découvrais de plus
en plus de projets solidaires d'intérêt
général je pourrais vous dire ça a été
le déclic
il ya eu un avant après à l'américaine
où tout a changé mais c'est pas vrai ça
ne s'est pas passé comme ça je me suis
plutôt dit ok je suis tombé sur une
sorte de caverne d'ali baba
et c'est fou ces projets qui ont pour
ambition de changer le monde mais et moi
dans tout ça alors je vais continuer à
tester différentes formes d'engagement
citoyen et j'ai découvert trois raisons
de s'engager sur des projets solidaires
sont pas si évidente que ça
la première raison c'est qu'on rencontre
des personnes géniales
je travaillais un an chez ashoka qui a
un réseau mondial de 3000 entrepreneurs
sociaux et mon travail c'était dans ma
compagne et 20 dans le changement
d'échelle de leurs projets j'ai jamais
vu autant de gens avec des étoiles dans
les yeux pour mon âge c'était une chance
de travailler avec des personnes aussi
inspirante qui travaillent sur des
problèmes de société aussi grave
la deuxième chose dont je me suis rendu
compte c'est que quand on aide les
autres c'est pas uniquement pour
contribuer à un monde un peu meilleur
c'est pas désintéressée c'est aussi
parce que ça nous rend heureux
par exemple il ya quelques mois avec
plusieurs associations
on a organisé la première journée
wikipedia sur des projets de solidarité
concrètement on a réuni 60 personnes qui
en une journée on crée ou enrichi les
pages wikipedia de 15 projets solidaires
par exemple le mouvement colibris de
pierre rabhi n'avait même pas de page
wikipédia alors qu'il remplit tous les
critères
en quelques heures des participants ont
créé une journée wikipédia ça contribue
à rendre le savoir accessible à tous ce
qui est la mission de wikipédia est ici
à démocratiser ces sujets de solidarité
mais pas que c'est aussi l'organisé avec
une super équipe et des partenaires qui
croient s'amuser à faire un truc qu'on
n'a jamais fait voir des débutants qui
ont peur de contribuer à wikipédia qui
ont l'impression qu'ils vont tout casser
les voir cliquez sur publiées et créer
leur première arctique et inversement
voir des contributeurs bénévoles experts
de wikipédia ravis de partager leur
passion et de former des débutants et si
on peut refaire ça chaque année avec à
chaque fois plus de gens qui apprennent
à contribuer à wikipédia
ça devient intéressant est la troisième
raison de s'engager sur des projets
solidaires c'est qu'on apprend beaucoup
de choses sur soi même
les sociologues le 10 mars sur blanc
s'engager répond à une quête identitaire
s'engager permet de se trouver ça permet
de se tester d'explorer des facettes de
soi qu'on connaît peu de se demander qui
on a envie d'être et à quel monde on a
envie de contribuer sauf que tout ce que
je vous raconte toute la richesse que ça
peut nous apporter de l'extérieur ça se
voit pas du tout avant de s'engager on
en a aucune idée
de l'extérieur on voit surtout tous les
freins qui nous retiennent d'agir
on se dit c'est pas pour moi je suis pas
militant je suis pas hippie lieu c'est
pas pour moi il ya personne autour de
moi qui fais ce genre de choses donc je
sais pas trop et j'ai pas le temps
on connaît mal les moyens d'agir à notre
portée et encore moins tous les projets
solidaires qui existent auquel c'est
facile de contribuer alors j'ai écrit un
livre ça s'appelle changer le monde en
2h
c'est pas une recette miracle
c'est un guide pratique qui présente des
micros engagement des moyens faciles et
rapides d'agir un peu plus pour les
autres et la planète avec un micro
engagement c'est plus facile de passer à
l'action
la marche à franchir est moins haute
et derrière c'est une porte d'entrée
vers cet univers solidaire et tout ce
que ça peut apporter comme un critique
gastronomique on va goûter les plats des
meilleurs restaurants
je suis allé à la rencontre de projets
solidaires pour tester les micros
engagement qui propose me mettre à la
place du lecteur expliqué ensuite
comment contribuer à tel ou tel projet
étape par étape
aujourd'hui des lecteurs me raconte
régulièrement comment ils sont passés à
l'action
et surtout pourquoi d'ailleurs c'est
d'électeurs qui m'ont envoyé cette photo
ça peut être quelqu'un qui a été
bouleversée après les attentats à paris
ça peut être quelqu'un qui a vu le film
demain sur des initiatives positives et
qui s'est dit pourquoi pas moi
qu'est ce que j'attends pour rejoindre
tous ces gens qui s'activent ça peut
être un prof qui veut sensibiliser ses
élèves ou une maman qui s'interroge sur
le monde dans lequel ces enfants vont
grandir
au début je pensais simplement écrire un
livre et en voyant le nombre de
personnes à qui ça parler j'en ai fait
mon métier
aujourd'hui l'objectif c'est d'écrire un
livre par an sur une nouvelle sélection
de projets et de micros engagement
d'organiser d'autres journées wikipedia
est de continuer à monter des projets
pour aider les gens à s'engager
les entreprises les collectivités parce
que il ya tellement de citoyens qui
s'ignore
je suis sûr qu'il en a dans la salle
c'est en ont marre que tout aille mal
thierno oumar de sentir impuissant face
à tous nos problèmes de société parfois
il suffit juste de montrer aux gens par
où commencer
vous vous souvenez de microdon dont je
parle et on peut se dire donner quelques
centimes à une association ça va pas
changer grand chose
et bien si cette année ils ont reversé
un million d'euros à des associations 1
million et c'est que le début et l'autre
projet let's do it
ils ont mobilisé deux millions de
personnes pour nettoyer les zones les
plus sales de la planète dans 110 pays
pourquoi vous êtes venu à cette
conférence
pourquoi vous regardez cette vidéo sur
internet pour être inspiré mon but c'est
pas de vous inspirer
mon but c'est que vous passiez à
l'action demain vous allez reprendre
votre vie normalement mais si tout ça ça
vous parle
ça résonne et que vous avez envie d'en
faire un peu plus bien maintenant la
balle est dans votre camp
parce que l'essentiel c'est d'agir est
le meilleur moment pour passer à
l'action
c'est maintenant et ça peut être très
simple si on agit un peu mais plus
souvent et qu'on multiplie par des
millions de personnes
oui sachant de la société bien sûr que
c'est compliqué de changer le monde mais
pas d'agir à son échelle et si tous les
jours une personne de plus agi pour les
autres et la planète alors
mathématiquement oui ça change le monde
une personne à la fois